something of cooling happened to you
[Music]
to lose how you lost
that's a long time ago pain doesn't have
time here
we've been through some bad things but
we take care of each other
this place is safe when was the last
time
you really let go of sound
most people are scared of pain
but they don't know how warm they can be
i think i'm seeing things you're here
because you needed belief
but your grief wants chaos
something happened here something
violent
is there someone frightening you here on
the island
oc island isn't it beautiful
we are gonna have ourselves an adventure
we can give you a room
thank you this has been a really tough
year
you're in exactly the right place it's
exactly the right time
plus he needs to be in balance
and you can heal it it will understand
you
know you they will love you back
everyone here is acting like something
bad's gonna happen
not all of us can be healed
ever since you came this island's been
divided
but we're all in agreement now
you